foreign
Chris is with us in New York City hi
Chris welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Christina how are you guys
doing great how can we help
doing well
um so my headline question and I can
give you the context is how do you
decide if it's worth in their life to
move based on the cost of living from a
personal finance perspective
uh me personally I'm kind of on the
fence of where I live now with the
strike the fact I'm doing well I like my
job I mean I'm 25 have uh 150 000 annual
income 100 000
save away in retirement funds uh you
know only a couple hundred dollars of
that
and it's just an interesting time right
now because New York City in particular
like the rent rates have gone through
the road the taxation rates are you know
I don't even have to tell you how high
they are so how do you kind of in your
experience when has it when have you
seen it you worked at the to move if
someone's already you know if I like my
job I'm doing well but you know the cost
of living where I happen to be is just
so astronomically High versus like
almost anywhere else how great it is and
most of that cost living is real estate
in your case
compared to the rest of the country it's
bizarre you got to make a lot of money
you do make a lot of money
congratulations do you think you can
make a similar amount of money somewhere
else
yeah so that's I think the biggest
problem because it's like there's this
risk where
um I'd have to go out and search really
hard to find another job I haven't I
haven't yet to be honest I'm gonna have
skin gold but and you really like you
don't see it that high what do you do
uh I mean you might not like this to
some extent I have a stock market
researcher so on individual companies I
mean I don't dislike that at all
somebody somebody needs to research it
I'm not against the stock market I buy
mutual funds all the time and those
mutual funds depend on Research so I've
got a a friend that um is um
uh a young a young friend for a guy 62
he's in his 40s and uh he makes about
300 to 400 a year and he does uh
research and analytics for one of the
big mutual fund companies and he does it
from his office in his home and has for
10 years before work from home was cool
he was doing work from home and he has
lived uh in ski resort areas he has
lived in um uh Nashville now uh and so
forth and so I you know I think you can
do your job and the job of analytics
from almost anywhere and I don't think
they require you to be in the city
physically anymore
yeah I that's definitely the case it's
an interesting
we were totally welcome home now I got
I think it's like
30 days a week
um so yeah but I'm saying there might be
the competitors or there might be people
in a specific Fields using your same
skills uh a certain industry that you
research and you become known for that
industry for one of the mutual fund
companies or something like that that
you can do totally work from home my
buddy did it before work from home was a
thing
yeah and you think in most cases it's
probably worth it at this I mean
especially if I start it's what you want
where do you want to live I mean you're
a single guy I take it you live in New
York City it's very cool and very fun to
live in New York City in a lot of ways I
love visiting there I personally it
wouldn't be the quality of life I want
to live there but I do enjoy the city I
used to enjoy it a lot more than I do
now
it's kind of screwed up up there right
now but the uh but it's a great town
it's got a great Vibe I love the energy
I love New Yorkers people that have
lived there their whole lives and stuff
I just I always relate to them because
they're high energy they're butt kickers
they get it done I like the environment
I like the culture of it but I still
wouldn't want to live in the city I got
enough country boy in me I want some
green grass
yeah so it's interesting you mentioned
that because I'm originally from from uh
from upstate New York but after 11 year
the past like two years I've come to
like the area you know I have a lot of
family and friends connections here yeah
so well there's nothing there's nothing
wrong with staying there you're not
doing anything morally wrong you're not
being irresponsible you make enough
money to live there but it's going to
cost you more to live there so you're
not going to prosper mathematically as
much as if you made 150 somewhere else
so it's okay to move there's nothing but
but if you're wanting us to tell you to
move we're not going to tell you to move
now if you told me you made sixty
thousand dollars a year and you couldn't
make ends meet on Manhattan I would say
that's true you're probably not living
in Manhattan making 60k it's probably
not happening uh I mean you might for a
little while but it's that's a tough one
yeah and with his career field he has a
great chance of that income continuing
to increase so I mean if you love New
York if that's somewhere where you want
to stay and you see
um your salary continue to go up then I
think eventually you'll have more margin
to save yeah what I would do is say
where do I want to build my life today
and by the way it's not doesn't have to
be permanent uh where do I want to build
my life tomorrow in the next season of
my life I mean you might say hey I want
to stay here and you might marry a lady
and you both decide to stay there or you
might go hey we're going to move and
raise kids in a different environment
you could do that any of those things
will work any of those things will be
fine so it's just a matter of what you
guys want what you want to do and later
if there's a you guys what you guys want
to do later but um
you know you should make those choices
based on uh lifestyle as long as the
math will work and in your case you've
got the option because the math works
yeah
yeah this would be a totally different
conversation like Dave said if you made
sixty thousand dollars a year because
that would be a true challenge but
thankfully you have the margin right now
I do not think to be in your field you
have to stay there though
I think with your company you might have
to stay there but I don't think you have
to stay there to be in your field so I
would check that part out